- Her new Showtime
documentary is called Sheryl.
So what was it like to look back
at your life and your
career in this documentary,
was it kind of scary or weird?
- I think for me,
obviously I have like 30
years of my own career
and then I had a whole life before that.
I think people forget,
especially with social media
and stuff, that we're people,
and that behind the artistry
and the drive to be an artist,
there's a world of challenges in there
that made you want to
reveal your vulnerabilities
and write music and were
really quick to judge.
And so when Showtime came to me
and said do you wanna do documentary?
I was like, absolutely not.
- Yeah.
- And then I kind of warmed up to the idea
of telling the story about
the person, as opposed to
the person that wrote "All I Wanna Do"
and "Soak Up The Sun".
- 'Cause those are different
chapters of us, you know?
- They are.
And your big hits don't
necessarily represent who you are.
- Yeah.
- They give you an opportunity
to go out into the world
and play your songs.
But it's the deep cuts that really,
tell the story.
It's been an interesting thing
and I hope people when
they watch it feel inspired
and they feel like, oh okay, yeah,
I've gone through depression
or I've had, you know,
sexual harassment in my life or, you know,
or I'm getting old, and what
does that mean in my career?
You know, that kind of thing.
There's all kinds of challenges
that we all go through
whether you're famous or you're not.
So, and that's what it's about.
- Was there anything, because
this happens to me sometimes
it's only been 20 years
for me, but I just mean,
it happens to where
somebody will say something
and I'll be like, oh my God,
like, was there anything
in the documentary that you were like,
surprised you about yourself?
Or like what happened
or you didn't remember.
Okay. I wanna know what's happening.
Okay. I wanna know. I wanna know.
I wanna know, you don't lie,
I wanna know what's happening right now.
- This is total vanity.
I mean, it's so stupid.
- I'm so excited.
- First let me just preface it,
by saying that my kids say, mom, you know
you were born in the 1870s.
- All our kids think we're old.
- I know. And when I watched it,
I was like, oh my God, I'm so old.
- No, I do see pictures,
and I'm like, oh, for me, like, I'm like
I see pictures, and I'm like, oh my God.
- Like, oh, you're not. You're not.
- I don't even care.
- But that's the thing,
I don't usually care.
But when you're watching yourself, like
on a camera speaking,
you're like, oh my God
my mouth is so ugly.
Or then why am I making that
facial expression, you know.
- You're known mouth.
People love your mouth.
Like's so funny.
- They do?
- You're like known for it.
- Did you love that?
- No, but you're no, that's
like one of your things, what
it's so see, this is why.
Okay. So I don't watch.
- You can't watch yourself.
- I don't watch myself.
I don't watch interviews.
I don't watch any, I don't watch myself.
I don't or any articles that
review anything like that
because I think it changes you.
And I think the things
that people love about you,
you'll change them.
And that's what people love.
So do you do that?
Do you read anything?
- No, I don't. Since my second record.
I've not read one single thing.
I don't want people to tell me.
I like being there.
Feel good about it.
And then I don't want somebody to,
yeah, rob me of that by
telling me that it wasn't good.
And sometimes I'll be, I'll
be like that wasn't very good.
But I'll own that.
I just don't want somebody
else telling me their opinion.
- Stay on your own front porch, sir.
- Exactly. Who asked you?